The JavaScript console in the Chrome Developer Tools can be
accessed by clicking on the Console tab, if it's not already open, and
is actually a full featured JavaScript interpreter.
We can execute any arbitrary JavaScript, 5 plus 7, and we get returned 12.
Or we can even create functions, and
when executed, gets add to the scope of the console window.
Here, we can see I defined a function named my_fun, and
when called, simply returns hello world.
So inspecting that in the console.
Notice as I start typing my, the Chrome console knows that
my_fun has been defined and tries to auto-complete it.
Typing tab, I can auto-complete it.
And if I leave the parenthesis off,
what gets returned is simply the definition of that function.
This is a subtlety, but fairly important point.
The definition of a function, in this case, what should get
run when it's called is separate from actually running that function.
As you can see here,
my_fun without parenthesis, simply returns the definition of that function.
But if I called my_fun with parenthesis,
it signals to call the function and return hello world in this case.
If your console window is getting too cluttered, you can use a clear function,
or if you're on a Mac Cmd+K to clear out everything that's been run before.
Also, if you type the up or down arrow keys,
you can scroll through the history of commands which you've run in the console.